absolument de se laisser aller aux idées
faciles monur le président Christian
Jacob merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
en utilisant l'article 493 en passant en
force en piétinant ainsi l'assemblée
vous reconnaissez que le pouvoir que
vous exercez avec François Hollande est
usé jusqu'à la corde la France n'a
jamais connu une telle déliquessence du
couple exécutif dans son Histoire
politique récente durant quelques mois
vous avez certes joué le le rôle de
parfeu pour François Hollande mais vous
ne le jouez plus la réalité est que
François Hollande est devenu monsieur 88
% de défiance et vous monsieur 80 %
d'impopularité vous êtes le chef de
gouvernement de la 5e République le plus
impopulaire plus rejeté par les Français
le plus par les
vôtreset image que vous renvoyez de
vous-même monsieur le Premier ministre
incapable de dialoguer incapable de
réformer mais ce rejet tient surtout
dans le bilan de la France votre bilan
de la France qui n'est rien d'autre
qu'un dépôt de bilan d'un pays qui a
gravement décroché depuis 4 ans cette
défiance tient au mensonge de François
Hollande qui a trahi ses électeurs sa
campagne de 2012 a été une véritable
imposture vous en payez le prix fort
regardez ce que vous avez fait de votre
majorité elle est devenu un véritable
champ de ruine face à un tel bilan les
Français ont dépassé le stade de la
déception ce qu'ils éprouvent c'est
l'écœurement et la colère Monsieur le
Premier Ministre colère après 4 ans
d'immobilisme colère après 4 mois de
manifestation incessantes de blocage
dans les transports de violence
orchestré par l'extrême gauche dans ce
contexte de rupture totale avec les
Français pensez-vous monsieur le Premier
ministre que ce soit encore une bonne
chose que vous restiez à
Matignon la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier Ministre manuel
Vals monsieur le
Président
Jacob vos questions se suivent ce sont
les mêmes j'essaierai d'être donc sur la
même veine dans la même
veine je prends d'ailleurs vos attaques
personnelles comme venant de vous autant
de de compliment honnêtement au stade de
la discussion et d'ailleurs assez
étonnamment dans une part monsieur Jacob
je vous ai écouté c'était agréable à
entendre donc si vous voulez bien
m'écouter quelques quelques instants
d'ailleurs ce qui est assez étonnant
peut-être pas d'ailleurs c'est que on
retrouve dans vos expressions al plus
personnel je dois dire les arguments
qu'on peut parfois entendre ailleurs
mais là n'est pas l'essentiel
oui
[Applaudissements]
oui même monsieur vquier est là c'est
dire que c'est un moment
important alors je réponds je réponds oh
monsieur Jacob ça arrive à tout le monde
d'en gagner et d'en perdre et si vous
êtes là minoritaire c'est parce que vous
avez perdu les élections en
2012 et Monsieur Jacob puisque vous nous
parlez du peuple il y a au moins une
chose qu'il faut respecter c'est la
parole du peuple c'est le respect du
peuple et les élections c'est en mai
prochain et attendez et attendez parce
que les Français sont au moins
mettons-nous d'accord là-dessus
souverain mais je vais répondre au fond
à l'une de vos questions de manière très
précise oui oui sur un certain nombre de
textes et de texte important nous
n'avons qu'une majorité relative et cela
je l'assume
je l'assume parce que c'est cette
réalité mais la Constitution et
d'ailleurs venant de quelqu'un qui se
réclame d'une formation goulis c'est
assez étonnant la Constitution nous
donne la possibilité de faire adopter
des textes en engageant la
responsabilité du gouvernement c'est la
Constitution une motion de censure ou
des motions de censure peuvent être
déposée si ces motions de censure sont
adopté c'est arrivé une fois sous la 5e
République chacun en
les conséquences mais je respecte la
Constitution et puisque il n'y a pas de
majorité alternative y compris sur ce
texte parce que reconnaissons-le le
texte travail porté par
meramcomery les critiques sont de nature
différent il y a ceux qui disent qu'il
n'y a rien ou qui proposent d'ailleurs
leur projet et c'est tout à fait normal
nous l'avons vu au Sénat et il y a ceux
qui disent qu'il y en a beaucoup trop et
qui manifeste leur opposition ici au
Parlement ou dans la rue et donc dans
ces moments dans ces moment moment
difficile pour le monde pour l'Europe
suite au brexit y compris pour notre
pays face au défis qu'il affronte malgré
des résultats économique qui aujourd'hui
vont dans le bon sens malgré la maîtrise
parce que franchement monsieur Jacob
ministre de l'Intérieur aurait aussi pu
vous répondre vous décrivez une
situation je sais bien que c'est le jeu
de l'opposition d'exagérer d'être dans
la caricature mais très honnêtement
pourrait d'ailleurs parler de ceux qui
nous proposaient il y a quelques
semaines par exemple d'annuler les fans
zones voire de reporter l'euro de foot
voir d'annuler il y a quelques mois la
COP 21 donc soyons sérieux restons de ce
point de vue-là maître de ce qu'est la
réalité du pays monsieur Jacob s'il n'y
a pas d'alternative à ce texte j'ai en
effet engagé ma responsabilité c'est ma
responsabilité c'est l'idée que je me
fais de l'exercice du pouvoir et comme
premier ministre je continuerai avec
cette majorité relative à gouverner
parce que c'est ça le mandat que j'ai
reçu des Français